what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and if you've been
following the channel recently or just
been following marvel news in general
you know that this past weekend was
disney's d23 expo and marvel studios
along with lucasfilm had their panel
this past saturday now during this panel
a lot was revealed about phase 5. we got
the official cast for the thunderbolts
we found out that the leader is
returning and is going to be the main
villain of captain america 4 and during
their presentation they revealed a lot
of new footage and a lot of trailers for
phase 5 projects yesterday i went over
the footage that was shown for black
panther 2 wakanda forever and today
we're going to be going over the loki
season 2 footage that was shown and also
some new ant-man and the wasp
quantomania footage that was shown we'll
be linking that to loki season 2 and
kevin foggy also did confirm some major
things about quantum mania that connect
directly to the avengers the king
dynasty so we'll be breaking all of that
down in this video and of course if
you're new to the channel and want to
stay up to date on all the latest marvel
news be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos so
the loki season 2 footage that was shown
at d23 is quite interesting one scene in
particular kind of offers us some
clarity of what we saw at the end of
loki season one where loki found himself
back inside of the tva and he went up to
mobius but mobius had no idea who he was
then loki noticed that where there used
to be statues of the three time keepers
there was now a statue of king and at
the end it really seemed like the
multiverse was broken and it gets even
more weird with this footage in this
preview footage we see loki back at the
tva he is reading a manual before he
greets somebody off screen but in the
middle of his hello loki actually
glitches and the reason that he glitches
is that he isn't actually supposed to be
there and he glitches plenty more in the
scenes to follow we see a scene of loki
fighting his way down a hallway and he's
still glitching we then see loki get
ripped through time kind of like
somebody is dragging him through
different timelines it's definitely not
on his own will so it seems like kang is
the one who is actually pulling him
through multiple different timelines we
then hear him say i've seen terrible
awful things we also see a scene of loki
chiseling away at the walls of the tva
to reveal the big brass face of king the
conqueror loki looks at the wall and
says war is on its way we then get
introduced to a new character the famous
actor ki hoi kwon appears to be playing
a tva archivist we know that loki looked
through the archives at the previous tva
so i'm assuming that this character is
going to be there to show us that the
tva is not the same as the one that we
knew before and i'm sure that the
archives are all going to be different
than the previous tvas in fact the whole
history of this particular tva is
probably going to be very different in
fact it does kind of show that in the
final scene which we'll talk about in
just a bit but before the final scene we
see a couple of other scenes we get a
glimpse of an old hollywood movie
premiere and we see sylvie listening to
records in a music shop loki and mobius
get a fun costume change as we see them
in old vintage tuxedos they could be on
their way to that old hollywood movie
premiere that they showed we're not
really too sure what this scene could be
about they're probably looking for
somebody at some point in time but if
you recall we've actually seen photos of
these they were released very recently
some set photos of loki in costume and a
tuxedo and of course of owen wilson and
a tuxedo as well we then see loki
falling through the middle of the tva
building which i'm assuming is at the
end of him being ripped through time but
here's the final scene and it's actually
quite cool we see loki and mobius
sitting across a lunch table from each
other just like we saw in the very first
season however you can tell that things
are very different and then we see loki
say to mobius i don't want you to think
i'm the bad guy in all of this and
mobius says who says you were loki says
iron man captain america hulk black
widow hawkeye phil coulson thanos nick
fury my father my brother miss minutes
you in which mobius just looks at him
and goes hmm and that was the footage
that was shown for loki season 2 at d23
and as you can see it is quite
interesting it's been established now
that the tva that we saw loki at at the
end of season 1 is a completely
different tva when sylvie killed he who
remains they really did shatter the
multiverse and we don't really know the
whole entire rules of the multiverse now
that it's broken could there be more
than one tva overall nobody at the
current tva where loki is at knows him
but throughout this trailer the overall
vibe is that loki is trying to warn them
of what is to come he's trying to warn
them about kang the conqueror and it
looks like king might actually know
about loki as we see loki being ripped
through time i can only assume that this
is kang because he is the one who is the
master of time but of course it could
always be the tva if they do perceive
loki as a threat which they probably do
but again now the multiverse is broken
whereas before the tva was dealing just
with a sacred timeline and now they are
dealing with a bunch of different
timelines so who knows where their heads
are at right now but make no mistake one
thing that we have learned is that the
tva is definitely not the same now of
course we know that loki season 2 is
going to directly connect with ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania quantum mania
is coming february 2023 and loki season
2 will be coming in the summer of 2023
and ant-man quantomania is going to
serve a very very important purpose and
that is to introduce kang the conqueror
a true king the conqueror now yes the
movie of course is important in many
other ways like introducing cassie lang
as stature bringing hope back janet van
dyme hank pym overall it's going to be a
very important movie but it's the first
time that we're going to see the true
kang as a villain not he who remains but
a kang the conqueror and kevin feige did
confirm at d23 that ant-man 3 quantum
mania is going to set up in a very very
direct way avengers the king dynasty now
of course we assumed this but keep in
mind kevin feige has already confirmed
that there are going to be multiple
variants of kang they did also confirm
on stage at d23 that loki season 2 is
the project that connects the entire
multiverse together so loki season 2 and
ant-man and the wasp quantomania are
going to be extremely important projects
leading into the kang dynasty and secret
wars now they did show footage of
ant-man quantomania which we'll talk
about a lot of it is the same as before
but it does have some new parts added to
it in the footage that was shown at d23
we see scott lang having lunch with
jimmy wu jimmy wu is returning we see
cassie his daughter showing her dad a
machine that is sending a signal into
the quantum realm janet tells her to
turn it off but then the machine sucks
the whole family into the quantum realm
there we see bill murray we see king the
conqueror telling scott lang you're an
avenger have i killed you before which
again is an insanely cool line i love it
but perhaps the biggest reveal of the
new footage that was shown for ant-man
quantum mania was the fact that scott
lang has to perform a heist for king the
conqueror apparently kang tells ant-man
that he took something from him or he
lost something due to some of his
actions so kang holds scott's daughter
cassie hostage and says that if he wants
to get her back alive he'll have to
perform a heist for him to get something
for him now at this point in time we
have no idea what this is but i am
assuming it's something relating to the
multiverse and the quantum realm since
ant-man is the one who has the ability
to go in the quantum realm it could be
some ancient relic from a cosmic entity
that affects the multiverse whatever it
is i'm really excited to find out and
i'm really excited to watch this movie
and especially see it connect to loki
season 2 and to see them both connect to
the kang dynasty and secret wars so
that's it for the footage that was shown
for loki season 2 and the new footage
for ant-man quantum mania let me know
what you think about it in the comments
down below and let me know what you
think kang could be searching for that
he needs ant-man to get please don't
forget to like the video and of course
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss any of the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof